النواب الامريكي يفشلون لليوم الثالث على
التوالي في انتخاب رئيس المجلسهم
مؤقتا كيف ترفض و برلين واشنطن تتفقان على
ارسال مدرعات قتاليه الى اوكرانيا
[تصفيق]
واسعه في السجون دعما للاحتجاجات
[موسيقى]
طب ثم طابتها اوقاتكم اهلا بكم الى نشره
الاخبار من العربيه ارجع مجلس النواب
الامريكيه الى ظهر الجمعه جلسه انتخاب
رئيسنا له وذلك بعد فشل الاغلبيه
الجمهوريه اليوم الثالث على التوالي في
حشد الاصوات اللازمه لانتخاب مرشحي من
مكان في رئيسا للمجلس وعلى غرار الجولات
الاقتراع الست العقيمه التي جرت يوم يا
الثلاثاء والاربعاء هذا النواب الخميس
باصواتهم في خمس جولات اقتراعا جديده
لكنها بقت كلها بالفشل ان لم يتمكن مكارثي
النائب عن ولايه كاليفورنيا في اقناع
حوالي 20 نائبا جمهوريه
الرئيس السابق دونالد ترامب بنتخابه خلفا
لنانسي فلوسي
على رايهم بانه معتدل اكثر من ما ينبغي
مجلس النواب الامريكي بدون رئيس
بعد ست جوالات من التصويت على المرشح
الجمهوريه
[موسيقى]
داخل الحزب
انتخابات التجديد النصفي سمحت لجمهوريين
بالحصول على اغلبيه طفيفه داخل مجلس
النواب
222 مقعد لجمهوريين
للحصول على الاغلبيه لم يتمكن مكارثي حتى
الان من تجاوز عتبه 2003
ما يعني ان الازمه قد تتواصل
الاوكرانيه
روسيا تريد ان تتخذ من الهدنه التي
اعلنتها لمده 36 ساعه بمناسبه عيد الميلاد
غطاء لوقف تقدم الاوكرانيين في دومباز
مضيفا ان الحرب ستنتهي عندما يغادر الجنود
الروس اراضي اوكرانيا
والقوات بالقرب من مواقفنا ماذا سيمنحهم
ذلك فقط زياده اخرى في اجمالي خسائرهم
وكانت رئاسه الوكرانيه اعلنت رفضها للهدنه
الروسيه ووصف مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني
ميخائيل البطريرك هدنه الرئيس الروسي بلا
ديمير بوتن بالنفاق والفخر
انسحاب القوات الروسيه من كمل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه التي سيطرت عليها لقبول الهدنه
المؤقته
من جهه قال الامين العام للامم المتحده
انطونيو غوتيرش ان السلامه في اوكرانيا
التي مزقتها الحرب لم يلح في الافق وان
المحادثات بين موسكو وكيف لانهاء صراع
ليست ممكنه بعد
الى وضع حيث نرى السلامه في الافق القريب
السلام الذي نعتقد انه يجب ان ياتي يوما
ما السلام المستند لميثاق الامم المتحده
والقانون الدولي
فسيق ذاتيه يعتبر الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدينا اقتراح حموسكو بشان الهدنه مع كيف
بمناسبه عيد الميلاد الارثادوكسي ان
الرئيس الروسي بلادي مربوط يحاولوا تنفس
السعداء اما وزيره الخارجيه الالمانيه
اليانا بير بلوك فقالت ان وقف اطلاق النار
لا يجلبوا للحريه ولا الامان للاوكرانيين
في المقابل قال رئيس المجلس الاوروبي شعر
ميشيل ان انسحاب القوات الروسيه من اراضي
اوكرانيا هو الخيار الوحيد لاستعاده
السلام والامن بدوره اعتبر وزير الخارجيه
البريطاني جيمس كليفر لي ان الهدنه
الروسيه لن تساعد في دعم افاق السلام في
اوكرانيا
اعلن البيت الابيض ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن والمستشار الالماني اتفق على ارسال
مركبات قتاليه مدرعه لمساعده اوكرانيا في
الحرب مع روسيا وتعتزم واشنطن وبرلين
تسليماكيبه مركبه بل مركبات مشا قتاليه من
طراز برادلي من الجانب الامريكي وماردر من
الجانب الالماني كما تعاهدت المانيا
بتزويد اوكرانيا بمنظومه دفاع جوي من
طرازي
في اوكرانيا اسلحه مختلفه تدخل ساحه
القتال حلفاء الغربيون يتحركون في اتجاه
امدادها بمركبه قتاليه مدرعه لاول مره
فرنسا اعلنت عزمها ارسال مركبه قتاليه
مدرعه خفيفه من طراز اي ام اكس
لكيف استراليا من جهتها قالت انها قدمت لك
اياها في 90 من مركبات التنقل المحميه من
طراز بوشماستر وهي وحدات مدرعه معززه ضد
الالغام ونيران الاسلحه الصغيره وتهديده
اخرى واشنطن هي الاخرى تدرس ارسال مركبات
براد للقتاليه الى اوكرانيا وهي عربات
مزوده بمدفع قوي من الوسائل الاساسيه التي
يستخدمها الجيش الامريكي لنقل القوات في
ساحه القتال منذ منتصف الثمانينات مركبه
من شانها ان تمنح اوكرانيا مزيدا من القوه
القتاليه وتعزز قدرتها في حرب الخنادق
اوكرانيا تستخدمه ايضا صواريخ فامبير تكيه
الصنع تطلق من راجمات صواريخ تقذف رشاقه
صاروخيه وتحمل الراجمه 40 صاروخا من
عيار22 ميليمتر تطلق جميعها خلال 20 ثانيه
في المقابل امر الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير
بوتين ادخال الفرقاطه الادمره القرش
المزوده بصوارخ تسكن الى الخدمه العسكريه
لتتمتع بقدرات عسكريه كبيره وتعتبر من
اكثر الروسيه تطورا لديها خاصيه حمل
صواريخ مختلفه منها كاليبر وكينج
يمكنها تنفيذ ضربات قويه ودقيقه في البحار
واليابسه صاروخ سيركونا الاستراتيجي فرط
الصوتي الذي يستطيع حمل رؤوس مختلفه ومنها
النوويه تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت قادر على
ضرب اهداف على مسافه تزيد عن الف كيلو متر
تطورات تاتي في وقت تتوقع واشنطن استمرار
القتال الانيف لاشهر اخرى في جبهه القتال
الشرقي
بلال الوجديني العربيه
في مدعم اقتصادي واعتداءات جنسيه على
سجينات وابقى موقع ميزان اون لاين التابع
للسلطه القضائيه وذكر الموقع ان مساعد
شؤون الدوليه في السلطه القضائيه وسكرتير
لجنه حقوق الانسان طلب من النائب العام
اجراء تحقيق مفصل في مزاعم الاعتداءات
الجنسيه والاغتصاب بحق بعض السجينات وكان
المتحدث باسم السلطه القضائيه اعرب عن
اسفه للتاكيدات الكاذبه حول التحرش الجنسي
بالسجينات وفي الثامن من الشهر الماضي نفذ
مصلحه السجون الايرانيه وقوع اي اعتداءات
ضد النساء في السجون وحددت بتقديم شكوى ضد
كل من ينشر مثل هذه المعلومات
تشتحو سجون ايران اضرابات على خلفيه تصاعد
عمليات الاعدام حيث تواصلنا 15 سجين
سياسيه الاضراب عن الطعام لليوم الثالث
على التوالي فيما ورد التقارير تفيد بتعرض
صحه السجناء للخطر وفق ما افدت به ايران
انترناشونال
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تحت عنواننا الطلاب
ضد النظام من اجل الحريه والتغيير كتبت
صحيفه واشنطن بوست الامريكيه نقلا عن
نشاطه ايرانيين قولهم ان الثمن الذي يدفعه
هذا الجيل من الطلبه للمطالبه بحقوقهم اخذ
في الارتفاع يوما بعد يوم واستشهادات
لايرانيين قبلتهم الصحيفه
يتعرض الطلاب للقتل والاعتقال والمنع من
الحرم الجامعي ولهم احكام طويله بالسجن
النظام يزيد الضغط على الطلاب للحد الاقصى
بحيث لا يمكنك المشي او ارتداء الملابس او
التحدث حتى الضحك بطريقه لا تتناسب مع
معاييرهما نحن ندرك جيدا انه بمجرد توقف
الاحتجاجات سيعودون الى اقصى ضغط لهم مره
اخرى
تلقت نقاباتنا تقارير عن قيام رجال الشرطه
بملابس مدنيه باختطاف طلاب في الحرم
الجامعي والضرب عشوائي من قبل قوات متطوعه
وتسبب وابل الغاز المسير للدموع والقنابل
الصوتيه وطلقات الرصاص على الطلاب
المتظاهرين في حدوث الكسور في الجمجمه
واصابات في العين
قال وزير الدفاع الاسرائيليه ايها افا قل
انت ان تهديد النوويه الايرانيه تصدر
الاولويات الدفاعيه لاسرائيل حسب صحيفه
تاجر
الصحيفه الاسرائيلي جورج بوست الصحيفه
اوضحت ان تصريحات الوزير جاءت خلال
اجتماعه مع رئيس جهاز الاستخبارات
الاسرائيليه مشيره الى ان الجانبين بحث
جهود طهران الرابيه لنشر الارهابي في
العالم
هذه نشره مستمره وفيها بعض الفاصل
شبح كورونا يطل من جديد سلاله فرعيه من
اومكرون تقلق بريطانيا وتنتشر في امريكا
حياكم الله في وقتنا عقدت فيه المعارضه
التركيه اجتماعا للتنسيقيه لتنسيق الجهود
الى الانتخابات القادمه هكذا الرئيس
التركي رجب طيب اردوغان في خطاب امام
اعضاء حزبه ان موعد الانتخابات الرئاسيه
والبرلمانيه المرتقبه يمكن تقديمه بينما
تبقى هويه مرشح المعارضه لمنافسه اردوغان
حديثه اجتماعات المعارضه
خطوات قليله فقط امام بدء الاستحقاق
انتخابي في تركيا بشكل رسمي الرئيس التركي
رجب طيب اردوغان اكد ان حسبه يدرس امكانيه
تقديم موعد الانتخابات دون الذهاب الى
انتخابات مبكره على حد قوله
الامتحان ده 20 ديس نحن الابواب اختبارين
جديد وانتم افضل من يعرف اهميه انتخابات
2023 التي ربما نجريها في وقت مبكر قليلا
بعد مراعاه الظروف الموسميه
المعارضه التركيه رفضت بعد اجتماع الطاوله
السداسيه وهو تحالف سته احزاب معارضه دعم
اي انتخابات مبكبكه نظام الانتخابات
الجديد وقالت انها تدعم انتخابات مبكرا
وفقا نظام انتخابات عام 2018 القضيه
الخلافيه الاساسيه لدى المعارضه وهي
المرشح المشترك لم يتم حلها في اجتماع
الطاوله السداسيه العاشره لكن زعماء
الاحزاب السته قالوا انهم بداوا مباحثاتهم
وسيواصلون الاجتماعات لاختيار مرشح مشترك
انجلش
يعني حزب الشعب الجمهوري هو من سيكون مرشح
مشتركا للمعارضه ما لم تعرض هذا الترشيح
عوائق او استطلاعات رايته تعطي شخصا اخر
الافضليه خصوصا بعد القرار القضائي بحق
اكرم الذي استبعد المنافسه
يريدون الترشح للرئاسه لكن الاكثر حظا هو
كمال كلشدار اوغلو رئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري الذي اسس هذه الطاوله وضامن
استمرارها حتى اليوم لكن ميرال اكتشنر لا
تريده مرشحا لرئاسه الجمهوريه
ميرال اكشن زعيمه حزب الخير ترى ان فرص
رئيس بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام موجلو في
الفوز بالانتخابات اكبر من حدودك ملك
الجدار اوغلو زعيم حزب الشعب الجمهوري
المثقل بعداء شريحه من المحافظين بسبب
مواقفه السابقه من قضايا عديده كانت تمسهم
بشكل اساسي خلال العقدين الماضيين
المرشح والمشتراك للمعارضه لا يبدو انه
هويته ستظهر خلال المدى المنظور في حاله
الشرق في الطاوله السداسيه وان حاول
الزعماء واخفائها لكنها كواليس غير بعيده
عن العدسات ولا شك ان توافق زعماء
المعارضه على مرشح وحيد هو اهم استحقاق
لهم خلال الانتخابات المرتقبه زيدان زينجو
العربيه اسطنبول
اعلنت وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه فرض عقوبات
جديده على اربعه افراد وكيانيين في تركيا
لدورهم في مساعده تنظيم داعش في التجنيد
وتحويل الاموال من العراق وسوريا واليها
واوضحت وزاره الخزانه في بيان لها ان هذه
الشبكه لعب الدوره الرئيسيه في اداره
الاموال وتحويلها وتوزيعها لتنظيم داعش في
المنطقه وان هذه العقوبات نتيجه
التنسيق والتعاون الوثير مع الجانب التركي
ابحر السفينه حربيه الامريكيه عبر مضيقي
تايوان في اطار ما يسميه الجيش الامريكيه
النشاط الروتيني لكنه يثيره غضب الصين
وقال الجيش الامريكي في بيان ان المدمره
المتحده بحريه الملاحه في منطقه المحيطين
الهندي
قالت هيئه الصحه الصينيه انها عقدت
اجتماعا مع مسؤولين في منظمه الصحه
العالميه حول الوضع الوبائي في البلاد
واضافت هيئه صحه الصينيه في بيان لها انها
قدمت تقريرا حول انتشار كورونا في البلاد
وما اذا كانت قد رصدت متحولات جديده من
الفيروس واضافه اضافه لخطه العلاج
والتطعيم كذلك
ومع زياده اصابات كرونا في الصين تشير
الاحصاءات الرسميه لوزاره الصحه الى
انخفاض عدد العاملين في المستشفيات من
الكوادر الطبيه بسبب الاصابات بكرونا فيما
سجل مستشفى تابع لكليه لكليه بجامعه
انخفاضا كبيرا في عدد العاملين بنسبه تزيد
عن 50% مضطر او وزاره الصحه الى زياده عدد
الاطباء والممرضين لاستقبال المصابين لحين
تعا في الكادر الطبي من الفايروس وعودته
الى العمل
انه متمسكون بوظائفهم والجميع منهمك في
العمل تحت الضغط كبير يجب ان نتفهمهم
ونتعاطفهم
للعوده الى العمل الثلاثاء العاملين في
الكادر الطبي من الشباب جميعهم اكدوا
استمرارهم في العمل
ساذهب للعمل كل ما كانت هناك حاجه اعمل
الان في عياده الحمه
المسؤول الطبيه بانني جاهز للعمل في كل
وقت
حضر خبراء الصحافه الولايات المتحده من
انتشار المتحول الجديد من ام كرونا
المعروف باسم اكس بي بي 1 5 في البلاد
وتحديدا في الشمال الشرقي وامكانيه
انتشاره بسرعه في بقيه الولايات الامريكيه
حيث تمثل السلال الجديده من المتحول نحو
41% من حالات كورونا المؤكده في امريكا
رفقه تحذير اخر هذه المره من خبراء الصحفي
بريطانيا الذين اكدوا ان المملكه المتحده
ليست مستعده لمواجهه موجه جديده
في ظل انتشار المتحول اكس بي بي 5 شديد
العدوى في البلاد وحتى الخبراء
البريطانيين على ضروره ارتداء الكمامه
المتحول اكس بي بي 1 5 تم اكتشافه في
اكتوبر عام 2022
[موسيقى]
يسبب اعراض المرضيه خفيفه مثل بقيه
السلالات اوميكرون
ينتشر في بلدان الاوروبيه وفي بريطانيا
والولايات المتحده
من الممكن ان يكون بوابه متحولا اخر اكثر
خطوره مع زياده عدد الاصابات
فتحت البصره بيوتها ومظائفها امام
المشجعين والوفود الخليجيه التي وصلت
باعداد كبيره لاول مره بعد غياب طويل
لحضور مباريات بطوله خليجي 25 في كره
القدم
هنا في منطقه الزبير غرب مدينه البصره حيث
مضيف الشيخ كاظم الصرايفي الذي بات من
اشهر الاماكن التي تستقبل وفوده ومشجعين
خليجي 25 اضافه الى سفراء دول الخليج
العربي
في هذه الخيمه وبين دلال القهوه العربيه
الممزوجه بالهيل العراقي استقبل هذا الرجل
البصري سفير المملكه العربيه السعوديه في
العراق عبد العزيز الشمري الذي حرص على
تلبيه دعوته البارح كان استقبالنا في
المطار استقبال رائع من قبل المسؤولين
الحكوميين
بعد ما طلعنا من مطار استقبلنا الجمهور
العراقي استقبل الفريق السعودي بمواكب
واعلام همم الى فندق
حقيقه اللي شفناه يثلج الصدر همم شيء مو
غريب على اهل البصره مو غريب على اهل
العراق
كاظم السرايفي همم ديوانه مفتوح وبيته
مفتوح وقلوبهم مفتوحه لكل همم
المشاركين في بطوله خليجي 25 من دول مجلس
التعاون فاحنا عند اهلنا وما هو غريبه
عليهم الكرم ولا هو غريب عليهم
رحابه الصدر اليوم اييه من القرائب الامام
الرقبل سعاده السفير اجا بروحه بسيارته من
فندق الشيراتون الى الزبير مسافه 20 او 25
كيلو
دلاله على ذلك يدل على الامان والمحبه
محبه اهل البصره اخوتهم الخليج
احتضان البصره لاحتضان اخوتهم الخليج
اليوم نشوف عندي اخوه اشقاء من الكويت بس
طرشت لهم اللوكيشن جاءوا للمضيف نظيف
لم يتوقف عن استقبال ضيوفه من كافه دول
الخليج العربي الذين فضلوا النزول عنده
للاستمتاع بكل ما هو عربي مصري من اجواء
هذه البطوله رحت بين همم الخليجيه ان ان
ان ان البصره افضل وان الامان والحمد لله
واحنا والله يعني نشكرهم على حسن
الاستقبال ونشكرهم على ما شاء الله وتبارك
الرحمن على هذه الحفاه وعلى هذه الجمعه
الطيبه
تفوقت المضاعف العربيه هنا على افخم
الفنادق في البصره حيث وجد ابناء الخليج
فيها القلوب مفتوحه قبل الابواب
من البصره منتظر رشيد العربيه
لقاء مع الطفله التي اهداها نجم النصر
السعودي الجديد كريستيانو رونالدو اهداها
الكوره بتوقيعه اثناء حفله تقديمه في ملعب
مرسول البار بارك
[موسيقى]
وزع كريستيانو رونالدو وعدد من الكور خلال
حفل تقديمي في ملعب مرسول مبارك لكن هذه
الكره كانت لافته الذهب كريستيانو رونالدو
وانتقل طفله صغيره من بين الاف الاشخاص
الذين يتواجدوا في الملعب هي الطفله
الوحيده التي او الشخص الوحيد حتى في
الملعب الذي ذهب اليه كريستيانو واعطاه
الكره اليوم
انت ناديتي كريستيانو ولا كريستيانو هو
الي جاك
لما جاك الكره
الناس اللي وراني ولا جنبي ولا انا كنت في
الجزء يعني بعيد مره
حد
يتجمع عليها
ايه عشان كده بتبيعين اهلي صح
مبروك عليها الى العناوين
لليوم الثالث على التوالي في انتخاب رئيس
المجلسهم
بوتين يعرضوا هدنه مؤقته كيف ترفض وبنين
الى اوكرانيا
اعدامات جديده في ايران واضرابات واسعه في
السجون دعما للاحتجاجات
شكرا لكم لطيب المتابعه القاكم بعد دقائق
قليله
[موسيقى]